hey caitlin hey evan so i'm gonna start
off the podcast with a very
difficult and complex question
okay
a question i don't even know how to
formulate that yet so let's work through
it okay
and if you don't if you can't answer it
we'll we'll figure it out together okay
but after five years on youtube yes
190 main channel videos yes
over 300 gaming videos
okay
220 supporter videos 82 podcast episodes
and now nine second channel videos plus
even more crafting streams and clips and
etc
do you feel
secure in like
our identity as youtubers
um yeah oh that's interesting let's talk
about that
let's talk about i'm gonna do the
outline first okay okay we're gonna talk
about like um a whole bunch of things
reflect on the five years of our careers
on youtube
big changes in our life and work and
stuff like that the future of the
podcast but yeah like i i i had this
question in my head and i've been like
trying to formulate how to ask it to you
while i was preparing this podcast i
honestly spent like
20 minutes just trying to like think of
like how to start this episode yeah
and it's and it's weird because like i i
totally feel like i understand so much
about youtube so much about content
creation so much about running a
business around that and stuff too
but at the same time like it still kind
of feels like we're making this all up
and it kind of feels like we're just
living our life and filming it and
people like that somehow
yeah and this is kind of like it's still
after five years
i'm secure in the business that we have
yeah and in in everything that we're
doing and everything but it still just
like
hasn't fully clicked with me that this
is what we're doing as our job i mean it
definitely does feel weird to me so like
i do have moments of like i kind of take
a step outside myself and i look at like
a snapshot of what
me or you or the two of us are doing in
any given moment and i'm like
it's just
weird that this is our job and it's not
just when we're doing like
you know the obviously weird things on
some of our projects but or just like
here at this desk playing games
yeah it's like it's weird though this is
our job and i think another thing hit me
the other day
um we're going to talk about how our
work-life balance has gotten a little
bit better which is
thank goodness um in a little bit but
like the other day i wanted to make some
personal time for me outside of work and
what did i choose to do
you made a project
i'll maybe show you guys some portion of
it later but i didn't want to film it or
anything like that i just wanted to like
go out there and make something yeah and
it's it's honestly pretty awesome um but
like i think that that was like another
moment uh for me it's like we are just
doing
what we want what we love
and somehow that's like
we now can just like justify the time
and cost it takes to do projects all
sorts of crazy things yeah that is true
yeah it's kind of crazy now the most
work part of our days is the actual work
part at the computer doing that like
coordinating editing uploading all this
stuff probably about like i think we
were talking the other day
25
of our
work is creating content
maybe maybe 20 like that
yeah maybe something like that
so much more of it is all the other
stuff all the other stuff yeah which
like
every
every time we create a piece of content
we're creating a bunch of other to-do's
for ourselves so like just filming a
video it's like okay well now we need to
process the footage it either needs to
be edited by me or one of the editors we
need to make a thumbnail for it we need
to
you know if it's a sponsored video like
a lot of ours are then we need to get
sponsor approval and
fill me up write the ad film the ad edit
the ad get sponsor approval the whole
process we got to upload it we got to do
the metadata we've gotten pretty good at
it yeah we know how to do it but like
filming filming one video
produces a lot of to-do's yeah um
i don't really know where i was going
with that oh yeah i guess i was just
talking about like the percentage of our
work it kind of depends on the projects
honestly if all we did
was our main channel videos
i wonder if it would be different
because those videos take so much longer
to produce yeah um than the other
content that we make
um so for those we might spend
maybe it would be 50 50 yeah working on
the project itself versus all the other
things i don't know
i think it's also interesting i was
listening to i'm kind of going
completely off script but i think i'm
trying to embrace it
we have an outline here i'm just kind of
going off off off the rails um i was
listening to another podcast colin and
samir
um
i i don't know their full whole full
story but they do a lot of deep dives
with other youtubers about other
youtubers channels um and i was
listening to them interview mkhd
and you know mkbhd mkbhd
you know we we a lot of letters yeah
yeah i'm sorry marquez um
uh and and he was saying that you know
at his core the main thing that he
brings is like he's like the idea
generator
and stuff like that and i think that
you know since
there's the two of us and we do have
editing help now um which we're gonna
talk about some but like and i think
maybe because there's so many different
aspects of our job
you know not just the content creation
uh but also like the ideation and the
like running the business and everything
like that i think that might be why i
don't like fully
fully feel like a youtuber because so
much of our job is the other parts of it
i don't know it's interesting i just
think of all these other parts that's
part of it i guess
i i don't know why but
like
it sounds kind of weird to say
i feel like
i
have
what's the best way to wear this in
terms of like
being a youtuber yeah i kind of feel
like i've had like whatever reverse
imposter syndrome is like i've been
oddly overconfident from the beginning
like when we first decided we were going
to start a channel we were just like
yeah we'll just start a channel i don't
know if we just didn't do enough
research into how difficult that is yeah
like we knew it would be a lot of work
um but we were just like
yeah you know we'll just start making
videos and someone will watch them you
know and then
i think i remember feeling
like a
youtuber after we hit 100k like 100 000
subs i was like okay we're doing it that
was like
a pretty big milestone whereas before
that it felt like we were still kind of
trying to become a legit channel yeah
you know i don't know yeah that's kind
of when it started feeling like it for
me and it's just
grown
as we've
figured out um you know like what's
what's the suite of channels we want to
do what various types of content do we
want to make because back then we were
just doing
like diy maker videos on one channel and
now we have a lot more now we have a lot
more we're doing a lot of different
types of content
so
um
i've always believed and us believed in
the channel believed in the success of
what we're doing i think i i kind of had
more confidence in it earlier than you
you were like
you didn't have any hesitations but
you're always like i wonder how long
this is going to last for a while oh
yeah well i still have that but that's
different
wondering how long it's going to last is
more thinking about the factors that you
don't have control over
it's like
will our video style just become like
dated and people don't want to watch it
anymore yeah will youtube change its
algorithm to favor something that
doesn't work with our content type like
you know is there going to be some crazy
uh you know law that comes into place
where now youtube is responsible legally
responsible for all the words said on
its platform and so it just like
you know kicks off 95 of its
creators just to be safe you know so
when i have those moments of like
not knowing what things are going to
look like in five years or whatever it's
more of the stuff out of our control but
it's not really about like
me
not
feeling like a youtuber or like i you
know am legit or whatever i don't know
yeah you know what i kind of missed
these podcasts just chatting with you
about like all these like things because
like we we talk all the time about all
of this constantly um but uh it's kind
of fun like bringing up some of these
topics and also working
through our feelings
with you guys well then we have like a
we're capturing a moment in time yeah i
feel like yeah yeah i think so too it's
crazy looking like looking back at some
of our podcasts man when i when i
watched the podcast of me after
appendicitis i'm like oh my gosh i was
like
barely there yeah you were out of it i
was so out of it it's crazy
i don't know why i thought it would be a
good idea to do a podcast when i was
like
like so out of it but hey it's it's
interesting looking back on everything
um
one of the reasons why i i personally
didn't want to do a podcast
for a bit
is because
for a while there
i felt like
and this is just me me personally saying
this you can speak on it
well you know
too i'd love to hear your your thoughts
but like i
kind of thought for a while there we
were saying the same things to you guys
and to our audience of like hey we're
gonna we're gonna get our
this out of control bus in control we
are going to start taking more personal
time we are going to figure all of these
things out and i think that we've been
like saying that for like
three years yeah
especially like a lot on this podcast
and it probably seems like more to us
than even to you guys because we brought
it up in
you know some of the podcast episodes
but
to each other or like to our families oh
yeah you've mentioned to our families
broken records like yeah oh yeah we
really we just got to get a handle on
things that we're really good we're
working this weekend no we can't make it
to that or whatever just an extra extra
rush mode sorry we're gonna have to you
know yeah this opportunity came up and
we just had to go for it or there's this
idea that we just got to rush on or
something just got real behind you know
the project took took a turn
yeah you know and i think that like i
just kind of didn't want to like
i don't know didn't want to talk about
this kind of stuff till we actually
have had some like had some change to
change to report and everything
yeah so so i wonder when the last time
we talked about that was probably around
the time we were moving because like the
only podcast between moving and now
we're appendicitis and uh you know
getting sick and every time we did like
our yearly goals remember we used to do
yearly goals for a while like
yeah 2018 2019
i don't know why i laughed like that
yeah we did
hey you know a lot of those goals we hit
yeah we know we did we did good stuff we
did
um yeah so i i think uh
we have made those changes but before we
get there
um let's talk about how the channels
change over the years yeah yeah so i
think
um i'm gonna need a lot of your memory
for this because i i have a bad
memory for
time and years and stuff
i think year one
was just getting our feet under us
yeah i don't think we know
no
year one how do you define year one year
one was
learning how to make
videos
yeah and putting enough out there that
there was some
semblance of hope
that maybe we could do this
yeah
yeah you're right because we i i was
still working you were still working for
most of your
and i'll just say like okay let's call
year one 2017 because we started the
channel in march of 2017. so if i just
look at it like that i think we quit our
jobs when did our did we quit our jobs
towards the end of 2017 i don't know or
was in 2018.
where's that video scroll scroll scroll
scroll scroll okay
did we do it going full time yeah we did
you don't work um yeah yeah i think
there it is okay
three years ago so let's see what date
that video is on that was in november
2018. so a year and a half in
is when
wow we quit our jobs i can't believe we
worked jobs for a year and a half while
doing this yeah no it was tapered
tapered yeah so like yeah i did
consulting yeah you quit your job and
you were doing consulting and then i
reduced my hours slightly and then i
quit and then you stopped your
consulting so it wasn't like all and
then nothing but i think
i think the first year i think towards
the end of the first year is when
you quit and started doing consulting
yeah anyways the first year was just
kind of us like
doing like proof of concept like is this
enough
for us to maybe do this as a job yeah
that's what i remember both both of our
parents were still pretty doubtful yet
supportive at that point
they're like
yeah i mean i don't wanna i don't wanna
speak for them um
my memory is sort of tied to like what
videos we were filming at the time yeah
um i think year two
was our year of like we're gonna say yes
to everything yeah was that year two i
think i'm trying to remember what year
that was but i remember that year that's
where we did all of the events all of
the the like so many collabs now yeah
looking at this that feels
i'm yeah yeah oh yeah we have videos
behind us yeah so we have alex steele we
did yeah we did a collab with bob from i
like to make stuff
we did um
crafted workshop yeah bill and britt
from punished but we did so many so many
clubs you know david from make something
yeah and we went to a lot of events like
i see i saw like our maker faire vlog
yeah
and so we were just like we will say yes
to everything
and we're just trying to like
meet other people in the community and
like go to every event we could we like
took on speaker gigs for events just so
that we could be there you know what i
mean i i i yeah
like be there with like the special
badge you know i was kind of like let's
just say yes to things and we'll figure
it out when we get there and caitlyn's
like
oh yeah no that makes me especially like
the speaking events thing yeah we did
our first um
speaker event when we had 40 000
subscribers yep
so
you know just
very much in the beginning
um so that's what i remember about year
two
was year three when we started
pushing our content towards a more
diverse
like uh
content type
year three i believe
was yeah um
playing around with our content to start
doing projects that weren't only like
practical projects bob ross tutorial
yeah we started doing like
we did the bob ross tutorials we tried a
few vlogs we tried oh you're scrolling
too fast um you gotta go back a little
bit um
we
uh did some silly things like can uh
epoxy cook an egg
also we started gaming and the podcast
gaming on the bottom it was like
diversify year yeah yeah yeah that was
right year one was like
start
yeah start your two was like say yes to
everything your three was spread out and
like see
kind of
what content type we like the best so we
tried so many different things yeah um
year
four
i think
um was year four
2020
2021 2020
i'm getting lost in the math here
was year four
so 2017 is year one 2018
is year two
2019 is year three 2020 is year four
yeah 20
17.
2018
i'm just going to write it down on our
notes
20 19
yeah yeah 20 21. so you skipped 20 20.
i was just testing you and thinking of
like the years you know we didn't start
january 1st we started in march but that
just kind of helps me like
picture the year as a whole easier so
year four
um
was 2020 and so we obviously couldn't go
to events and stuff anymore year four is
when we got much more serious about
streaming
we did
and yeah we definitely ramped up there a
lot it rammed up there a lot like
i think live streaming in general got
even bigger with everyone stuck at home
and um our stream started growing a lot
we started streaming a lot more and much
more consistently i think we're doing
like two to three times a week fairly
consistently yeah yeah probably closer
to three times a week yeah
closer to three on average pretty
consistently and then also continuing to
um
like add more and more like sillier
videos that's when we did uh we did
cooking with evan and katelyn oh yeah
yeah so we're really continuing to
diversify so it's kind of like a
continuation but i remember streaming
and i think that's when we started doing
our um crafting streams
yeah crafting streams um
so streaming
grew out that's when we became partners
i believe on twitch if i am remembering
correctly
i did not prepare
i should have prepared more um for some
of these specifics
so that's what i remember 2020 being
2021 was the year of moving yeah it was
the year that was our goal
we started looking at houses at the very
beginning of the year yep
you know
um and like a year and three months
later here we are
yeah yeah
um so what's the goal for 2022 aka like
what will be looking back on at the
sixth year
well i think i think like like one thing
that we kind of skipped over though in
in our fifth year we
we did the move
we set up all of the filming so it's
been it's been a big journey to get to
where we are here like yeah it wasn't
just like moving not just moving but
yeah setting up all of the filming sets
you know the garage one we have three
studios in our house
yeah yeah so if you haven't seen evan
and kalyn uncut that's where the uh the
third studio is yeah some of those
videos get edited for evan and katelyn
too yeah um i think the other thing this
is probably what you're leaning towards
towards the end of 2020. once we finally
had our feet under us a little bit from
the move and appendicitis and all that
we started
two things yep we started doing more for
the second channel yep and we started
bringing on our gaming editors for the
second channel and for the main channel
and we did the uncut
oh yeah we started that yeah that's kind
of a minor thing though that i think
that's pretty big
i think like starting the uncut channel
and splitting
evan and caitlin ii and evan and kalen
uncut that was a pretty big we we
i'm not saying it wasn't a big decision
i'm saying from like an outside
perspective it didn't change anything
yeah i didn't really we were doing
long streams and shorter edited videos
on the second channel and we just split
those into two channels yeah yeah that's
true so um but our focus on doing more
second channel videos and bringing in
the editors was a big change it just
didn't happen till the end of 2021 yeah
yeah we we fit it into the last little
bit of the fifth year but i think that's
one of the the biggest changes that
we've made you know
putting a little more time into second
channel content
growing that into something that can be
a big part of our brand and business
and everything like that um because and
just giving us an outlet for other
videos that we want to try
yeah but
we don't want to put
on the main channel because it might
like bring drag down the whole channel
average or like turn our normal viewers
off of the channel because it's so
different and we know that a lot of you
guys
wouldn't mind that content being on evan
and katelyn the people listening to the
podcast yeah um but you know
numbers don't lie
like yeah when we try doing cooking
videos on the makeup or the vlog
so we're like maybe this type of stuff
should be separated into a separate
channel you know and grouped with a
similar type of content exactly no
because we don't want to like also like
if we put out a vlog on evan and katelyn
and people are like wow i love this vlog
i want more and then they go to our that
channel and it's all diys
you know it's good to group like content
around like content
um
for for lots of reasons
um
but yeah so that was that was
changes the main changes in year five
and now we are entering year six yeah
and i think that like finally
at this point you know we we do have a
lot of channels we have the main the
second the uncut the gaming gaming uncut
podcast clips
is that all of them
well we have our two like personal
channels that we're just sitting on but
those won't
um those are
all the channels yes yeah and i think
that like at this point i feel like
if we want to do something and we want
to film it there's a place for it now
you know like like like to us
where things go is pretty clear and
everything
um
but uh and i think that that's kind of a
really good place to get to
and to like feel that
because like me personally i i have this
like
kind of
fear of missing out on an unknown
or something like that
unknown fomo unknown fomo yeah and like
i i i've you know for a long time we've
kind of been exploring and experimenting
to find what we like what we where we
want to go and stuff like that
and you know there have always there's
always been a slight question of you
know how many channels are we going to
end up with and you know what
how are we going to like fit
kind of like what i said in the very
beginning like we just kind of want to
like live our life film the parts of it
that we think would make for fun videos
and then put it out and now i feel like
we have a place for it all um that makes
sense to us
yeah so i think that's really cool for
2022 i don't know i'm pretty i'm pretty
cool with where we're at now okay so
here's my 22 goal
and
in terms of content
and stuff like in terms of the channels
i think it's kind of continuing down the
path we've been on i like the types of
videos we make i like the suite of
channels we have
i do want to experiment more with second
channel videos because that's kind of
like the new exciting thing
i'm worried what cursed cursed things
you're gonna come up with
yes i have been enjoying coming
um but i think my main goal is like to
be able to take
weekends yeah yeah yeah yeah even just
one weekend a day
a couple times a month oh no i'm going
to get more aggressive than that
i want to be practical
i want to have
by the end of 2022 i want to have
at least three weekends per month full
weekends like double dates oh no three
three days off okay
so it's only one more day than what i
was saying maybe five maybe i was saying
two days off using three days off a
month
five
oh
five a month
two to five days off
and that's not to say like we
to give us props
um we have been able to
do more family things this year yep and
more personal things yeah and more
personal things
we we
have made you know since moving here we
have since recently made like doctors
and dentist appointments which were
first time in a while for sure about
um you know we've been able to do some
house stuff like you know improving this
this house that we we loved and moved
into and it's kind of been like
completely underutilized and like you
know just like
well
we we haven't like moved
in
i still don't consider us fully like
settled in no not at all settled but
like we've been starting to like
the progress had been flat
absolutely flat for
like nine months
and now we're moving again house
progress house progress yeah you know
and i think that's that's great
yeah so we have been
able to
like devote some time to those things
that are
personal things yeah you know but we
haven't
the only time we've taken off just like
a day
to do whatever we want are on our
birthdays yeah that's true and there
have been some birthdays in the past
where we did not and we still don't work
but
soon i mean we we're we're getting
i think that we have taken some days off
though
just just because and we have plans to
take you know more days off have we
taken days off when like this year aside
from our birthdays
i think i kind of think of like pers
like family time maybe i'm like saying
family time we're taking like whole days
off yeah you know but i guess to me
that's kind of different because like
when you have an outside force that's
like hey
it's so-and-so's birthday we're gonna go
we're gonna spend the day together yeah
that's different can you guys come we'll
look at our calendar be like
yeah move this uh yeah okay but we
wouldn't
we wouldn't feel comfortable enough and
how in our workload
to
um
to just take that day off ourselves like
we make it happen and then we like pay
for it before and after yeah yeah okay
so i came up with
during one sleepless night recently i
came up with this analogy
and i don't know if it'll hold up now
saying it during the day to you and
everyone
but it's like evan knight thought yeah
um
the position that we're in right now is
strange
because most
jobs
you are an employee
and then
you have most people have bosses
you know
and as the employee you want to like do
good work and you want your boss your
job to treat you fairly and you know not
ask too much of you and stuff like that
but also
as kind of like a boss
in most companies
bosses are kind of incentivized to get
the most out of the employee that they
can
you know what i mean and like we are
both bosses and employees
and
like
the boss role of
like my mentality is like okay worker
evan
you enjoy the work
and you're gonna benefit from the work
so just work more
you know what i mean and like
i think that for the longest time like
worker
worker like
self
me
is like yeah i do like the job and i
will benefit so i'll work more
and like
it's unlimited work too because there's
there's there's no you can always do
more you can always do more than the
idealistic stream the ideal list is
always longer
than
like or the i the idealist increases at
a faster rate than we can
execute the ideas yeah yeah so we just
have to like keep on trimming down like
yeah like how excited we are about this
idea like nah that's not a five star
anymore it's a four star or three star
um but like you know i think that's kind
of a strange place to to be in
in a way because most workers can be
like okay i'm gonna go in for the amount
of hours i need to be in i can maybe go
a little bit extra sometimes if i want
to be like a super good employee or
whatever but like you know i need to be
protective over my own personal time
and we don't
it's harder for us to have that
mentality
yeah
because like the boss persona of us is
like well
why not just work more
i don't know and it's easier to ask
someone to work more when that someone
is yourself yeah
yeah
like the like
the amount of time that i expect myself
to edit a video i would never ask our
editors to edit in that time no never no
you know
[Laughter]
yeah and what does that say i don't know
yeah
yeah so i mean you know that's something
we've been struggling with but we've
made progress and we have and i think
you know
uh a significant part of it is you know
we we've been having the editors that
have been editing our gaming channel
content for years now i think we've been
working with one of our editors for like
over three years
maybe three years
and and that's that's awesome and
they've gotten to know us and our style
in this really organic way and it was a
easier transition to our main channel
content which was uh awesome or second
channel content
so i think that that's oh man that was
that was a very difficult transition to
make not for the editors
not not in any relation to like their
editing skills but
one reason we put off
you know getting editing help on the
main channel for so long is in order to
do that
you have to you know x amount of weeks
however long oh yeah you want to give
your editors to edit you have to
produce a video when we were making
videos
every other week it took that full
those full two weeks to do everything we
needed to do in those two weeks there
was no time to also film a video for
like a month from now yeah you know
um
and then doing that consistently so we
really i don't
fully know how we did it we just like by
sheer force of will
we're able to start filming ahead hard
days there's some hard days this is like
around the holidays last year's when we
started yeah um
pre-filming things instead of just it
was in december yeah immediate
next video
um so we had to start like planning
ahead and filming those future things
and being strategic about a few videos
we picked that could actually be
filmed ahead in order to get that ball
rolling and then once we started getting
editing help then it did like after a
while it did start um the amount of time
i was saving by not editing like our
time is kind of like collective there's
some tasks that are caitlyn tess and
some that are evan tasks but there's
also like our joint time so
freeing up me from editing
still freed up like our together joint
time to work on other stuff
and so now i do
feel like we're at a point where i don't
feel nearly as stressed about
filming and editing things like
we're finally far enough
ahead that it's not that big of a deal
to be filming for the editors
much farther in advance yeah and i'm not
sure where we've shared this before i
think we've shared it somewhere but like
one of the biggest stressors about this
is we pre-sell spots
and what that means is like you know
sponsor spots yeah so so video spots and
um
uh the great thing about that is like we
have some
you know we have some idea of our our
salary in a way you know what i mean and
like it's less negotiation with sponsors
for a full year yeah so it's less of our
time demand yeah we have a few sponsors
i'm sure you can guess who they are
who
we just signed multi-month contracts and
we fill up six months to a year at a
time
leaving a couple open spots for like if
anything spontaneous
yeah pops up but i think um
you know because of that
we have a set amount of work for the
year
and we had for the longest time been
setting that too high
you know we had been pre-selling
too many spots which just sets a pace of
work
that needs to get done that's like
was was just way too much that's true in
our defense every year that we pre-sold
this we did try reducing it's just
either we wouldn't reduce enough
or we would start something else up so
like
we reduced significantly but we started
the gaming channel you know yeah in the
podcast yeah the podcast or you know we
reduced significantly and then we
started doing other you know whatever it
was yeah um and so it's it's
um not us
purposefully or we've we finally take on
those bigger projects that take so long
or we moved or we moved it takes a lot
of time yeah huge amount of time and so
like we have been trying
actively to um
reduce what we're like in advance
committing to but it's hard to gauge
you know yeah but i think that like this
you know i think that i can't call it a
full success already
but in 2022 we have chosen a much more
reasonable thing
that's allowed us to add back in spots
yeah you know like multiple times we've
like you know we we committed to less
because i've always said we can always
add we can always add
more responses more spots more videos
but taking away
is is so hard we've never done it
i think
we once something fell through once no
we move when we moved we were able to
push things oh yeah we pushed um but
that it we didn't actually take a spot
away we just like
pushed everything by a month
yeah um and then it like
it kind of hit a place where it couldn't
be pushed any farther and then that was
a busy month yeah and then we did the
same thing when you got appendicitis
yeah we just moved things
but yeah we we had to deal with the
repercussions later
we're the type of people who would like
have a hard time breaking commitments
oh it's like contract contracts yeah
contracts
like we can we have there are clauses in
there we could have canceled yeah i know
but you know that's that's i don't know
we don't want to do that
yeah so um
uh i i i don't fully know where i was
going with that yeah but i think looking
at um you know us trying to make changes
in 2022 and how so far it's it's been
it's been great it's been great that's
why we have been able to like
see family more and like work on the
house more just in these past few months
and kind of like just do the ideas we're
most excited about whether that's a main
channel or if it's a second channel
because sometimes what we really want to
do is just a second channel video
sometimes yeah this is like that's just
like what we want to do and it's great
following and following through with
with what we just really want to do
um
and and you know
i gotta say sometimes the podcast wasn't
at the highest
for the longest time i mean do we want
to talk about the podcast
i mean i've like said this in passing a
few times but it's just there's only so
so many hours in the day
and um
i think the main thing that has
increased has been our second channel
stuff yep and
um something else has to go down so
gaming went down a little bit
maine went down a smidge and podcast
went down and part of that is because
that we don't
they're you know with maine
we can only reduce the schedule like
every six months to a year yeah you know
um
with
gaming
um i know not everyone watches on twitch
a lot of people just watch on youtube
but on twitch we have subscribers
and they're like paying monthly
you know
assuming that we're going to be
streaming like there's like a minimum
amount we want to do yeah um and also
the gaming channel is really like our
break
yeah of the work stuff we do
it's our break like we we really enjoy
being able to play like a minimum amount
of games in any given week
where is the podcast yeah um
there's no commitment to sponsors
there's no like
um
you know people paying a monthly
fee for it
what i also think like i was thinking
about this a little bit earlier i didn't
discuss it with you so much but i mean
when i was looking at how many videos
we've made
you know we've
made
more supporter videos
that some youtube members and patreon
supporters um then main channel
you know
we've made 220 supporter videos like and
i think that a lot of
the life updates a lot of the behind the
scenes on projects a lot of that stuff
it all goes into supporter videos it all
goes into supporter videos yeah and i
think that that's why like when we think
about podcasts we need to come up with
something like
bigger extra like because we still want
this to be good content for you guys and
or something very like topical based
yeah
because we can't just
you know the stuff that we are sharing
you know with people on patreon or
youtube members
it kind of like
loses its specialness if we just share
the exact same stuff in the podcast yeah
you know yeah and also i mean it's it's
kind of nice
with the the supporter videos and
content
like
i i'm just very casual and relaxed about
it for some reason yeah we don't need to
come up with like a title the title and
the
like that it's thumbnail
those are like the super subscribers and
for some reason i i don't know i don't
feel as much pressure
um on that side of things and we're like
podcasts i still feel
some of that pressure
yeah sorry because i moved my
mic away from me and maybe it's just
because like you know podcast that's
like a public facing number or something
like that or like i don't know or
maybe i i just i think it's more like
um
i think it's more about we put a lot of
the random little
life updates
into a type of content already
and the two are mutually exclusive
yeah you know
even like you know like we listen to um
some maker podcasts like
you know and they talk about what
they're making that way every time i
have this like curse every time you you
say some i want to say body
it happens all the time thank you for
resisting but then explaining anyway
yeah i just had to like i just had to
explain why i was like struggling not to
laugh
okay we listened to a lot of maker
podcasts but yeah and
a common topic is like what are you
working on or like how'd your project go
yeah we talk about that in our um after
shows yeah but also
we write down all the things we want to
talk about in the after show and we do
it all there but i think another
difficulty of the podcast is um
you know
a lot of podcasts are uh
people who don't live with each other
that's true
so they can be like catching up live
ketchup and just like kind of some of
that and i think that like you know
with with kayla and i there's no secrets
there's nothing that we don't talk about
which i love
um but
you know if we sat down for a podcast
the only way we could kind of share some
of those conversations with y'all is to
like rehash them it's hard yeah you know
what i mean we've already like talked
about everything yeah and it's it's a
little bit less like
i don't know
not genuine
it's like
it's not spontaneous because
everything that we want to talk about
we've already talked about previously
like just just us yeah
that's a good point so i think that like
you know
i i'm super glad that we have the
podcast channel yeah
um i'm i'm really happy that we have all
of our past episodes and i love that we
have it four times where we want to talk
in this longer form
with our our viewers and supporters and
everything like that
um
uh
and i do enjoy this this is nice this is
nice i think that like if we came up
with like uh like reoccurring show
concept or like you know which we have
done in the past yeah
um something that was like they didn't
like take a ton of time to prep or
something like that
i don't know i think that that the
future of the podcast isn't fully known
right now but i'm glad we have it and
you know i i certainly see us creating
more episodes in the future i'm just not
sure when i think it's just going to be
it's not going to be a regular schedule
it's going to be random yeah i think
it's just going to be random but look
we're doing one we're doing one where
we're congratulations congratulations
yes it's not an update on our a big
update on our health or
like yeah or moving moving yeah which
which the last i don't know three were
at least
yeah it was um
yeah covered appendicitis households
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know just living a nice quiet
easy life
yeah maybe we should do a q a or
something
yeah we could do a q a oh we'll figure
it out we'll figure it out um but i
think that brings us to the end
of the podcast you know what you know
it's a weird thought what's that
we've been
doing youtube longer
than any of our past jobs
wow not like all of our past jobs
continued yeah or combined
but like any individual past job
isn't that weird
so if you're still not feeling legit
just think about that yeah but before we
go we need to do thing of the week
yeah
i have a few things of the week i see
that
uh my first is gonna be
an admission too
i i've been using a fanny pack like
legit all the time
all the time
you know it's just like
you just want to grab all of the stuff
that you want yeah you don't always want
all that stuff in your pockets i know
and like you know when you when it's in
pockets you got to take it out and put
it back in yeah and it's not just my you
know phone or wallet or keys i also want
to bring like you know the my
uh water flavor packets or whatever your
true lemon juice from like you know uh
nose medication or like you know
allergy eye drops you know
i have a few spare band-aids and stuff
in there too a little like um uh pen
knife
i should have the pen knife
i'm going to add that too to your thing
of the week i think of it at least you
need to think of some more things for me
you don't need to i'm just going to have
i'm just going to put a whole bunch here
because i'm not sure when the next
podcast
so um my fanny pack was actually a gift
from your parents yeah from your mom and
it's an rei
trail to
waste pack
a waste bath
how do you
do you like the crossbody or the around
the waist it depends on the situation
sometimes i like around the waist
sometimes i like crossbody
but it's it's good that it's you know
it's a
it's not just a waist pack it's a cross
body pack too
but it's a it's a good it's a good size
it's held up well the zippers are good
um so i'll put it in the description um
but you know any any fanny pack let's
just get more people out there with
fanny packs so i don't feel bad
fanny packs are cool again yeah and uh
the other one is gonna be a little uh
swiss army knife you know like it's
interesting
i've always loved like multi-tools
and for the longest time i had these big
multi-tools
and then they got smaller and then they
got smaller and now it's just like the
little classic it has scissors
it has a knife
it has a file screwdriver
it has like a
toothpick and tweezers and stuff and
like that's it
and honestly
i haven't really missed any of the
bigger functions like that's mainly all
i need so i'm i think i'm i'm happy with
that as my like main edc
item wow yeah we'll see if you feel that
way around christmas still when you're
like what do i want
for now for for for
three or four months it's it's been my
favorite
since christmas
when you got it did you get two i got
two yeah
um
more things i'm just going to throw them
out there
in the back of my head i'm trying to
think to see if i have any others um uh
you know a lot of uh
a lot of people like noise generators at
night
we use one that's a fan an actual
physical fan that spins around and makes
noise so i'll link that in the
description the dome the dome dumb
it's cool i don't know i honestly
like i'm like how did we sleep before
because now if we don't have it and that
is one of the risks that's one of the
risks
but i'm like
how did we both like live in dorms yeah
and not have a noisemaker i don't know i
don't i don't get it i feel like i think
we need to sleep worse now
we need we need a more controlled we
need like a better bed better pillows a
quiet environment to
sometimes melatonin you know we need any
any help we can get
to sleep i think so it's so necessary
now
but as a backup sometimes like caitlyn
said we don't have our usual noise
physical noise maker which is kind of
big you need to plug it into the wall
and it actually uses a decent amount of
you know power to some degree so it's
not like you can run it off of usb or
anything because it's a motorized fan
i i've been on a search for a backup i
downloaded so many apps
and then i just like sat there and
listened to them to see if i could find
the moment where they repeat because
like i don't know about you guys but i
have the type of mind where i will
search for a pattern incessantly
and i will try to find it and i most of
the time do yes
and it really annoys me so most noise
generator apps i can't use because
there's always a loop
but i recently found out about like
frequency-based noise generators like
white noise pink noise brown noise brown
noise is the best noise even though it
sounds weird
i just think of the the fart noise yeah
it makes you poop your pants yep
but i found this like brown noise
generator that also has rng random
number generator like random noise
generator built in so in addition to
this brown noise that it's making it
adds natural randomized variations into
it that are like
algorithmic mathematical based and i
just love that
yeah and i think it's really cool it's
actually random it's actually random so
there is no repeat and i love it
so i'll put that and that's the free
alternative if you don't want to buy and
like the fan or if you want to travel
with it yeah i was going to say the
portable alternative yeah it's just on
your phone this is on your phone and i
think it uses less power too and
everything so
yeah i think it's uh it's pretty cool so
those are all of my i only have one
thing and i all i already shared it
during a stream because stream was
asking about things that's okay
hey you can do another thing of the week
no that's lame that's self-promotion
that's lame
no they're not lame but it's
self-promotion evan just pulled over our
charms but we don't even know when this
is coming out the charms are only
available until the end of march okay
if you want a charm we have gold charms
we'll link to that
oh i'll hold them up okay we make fail
and awards are hard and then evan has a
supervisor hugging a heart yeah you
might only have days left at this point
yeah yeah i wasn't gonna mention them
because they
um are not sold after march um
here's my thing of the week
i am someone you know how like if you
leave the house yeah you don't have your
phone on you you're like oh my gosh i
feel naked i don't have my phone
i am like that if i don't have lip balm
i need something on my lips
[Music]
should i go for it
i need something on my lips at all times
and if i do
and if i don't have it i start getting
like really anxious
like i'm just like so aware of how dry
my lips are like can you feel them
chopping right now yes i can and i want
i'm about to
use my thing of the week so
i've i've tried a bunch of different
like chapsticks and lip balms and
everything and my favorite thing is
aquaphor aquifer aquaphor i'm not sure
if i'm saying it right it's
kind of like vaseline but better better
i think it's different
i don't know if it's like slightly
different like proportions of things but
it's like kind of like fascinating
um
it stays on it's like the thing that
stays on the lawn now i need it and now
and i used to just get like the big tub
of it and i would like transfer some to
a little smaller little you know
portable tub like you would have lip
balm in but evan discovered there are
little travel
squeezy travel bottles yeah block our
faces little squeezy travel bottles well
you know i'm trying to hold it up to the
camera yeah
they're so good they're so good you
don't have to get your finger all sticky
i have one in my fanny pack
i have them everywhere no they're just
sprinkled throughout the house
they're so good
having in the travel pack
is so much better than like me
trying to like scoop the stuff out of
the big tub into the little tub and then
like
you know going in with my fingers they
last a long time yeah the little tubes
last a really long time so long yeah
yeah so
that's my thing of the week i was trying
to think if i could think of anything
else while you were talking but
um i couldn't think of
any other things but this is a good one
all right guys um hope you're having a
great day and look forward to seeing you
in the next video it probably won't be a
podcast though bye
[Music]
you